Okay,
welcome back for a,
for cosmology.
What I want to do today is,
um,
uh,
quickly review what we were doing about magnitudes and make a comment or two
about the problem set and then go back and talk about the implications of the
Hubble law and the Hubble Diagram,
which are,
uh,
a formidable to put it mildly.
Okay.
Magnitudes.
Uh,
there's a couple of these magnitude equations.
I'm just gonna write them down.
Uh,
the first of them looks like this.
and uh,
this equation is used.
Uh,
we focus,
okay.
So this equation is used to relate,
uh,
magnitudes of two different objects to each other so that we've got two
different objects and it can be used for either kind of magnitude,
either,
uh,
absolute or apparent magnitude just so long as,
you don't mix them.
So it's two different objects,
but only one of the magnitudes.
Uh,
one kind of magnitude.
And depending on which kind of magnitude you use,
this brightness ratio,
it's either the bright,
the ratio of how bright it looks or the ratio of how bright it is.
Uh,
whatever's appropriate.
Now,
uh,
on the help sheet on the web,
I sh I have this equation in a somewhat different format.
It's important to realize that it's the exact same equation.
Watch this.
Uh,
let's see.
Let's multiply both halves by minus two fifths,
which is minus 0.4.
So this is minus 0.4 m one minus m two is equal to log,
be one over B two.
And then let's take 10 to the power of that.
That gets rid of the log.
And this is now the form that it is on the help sheet,
uh,
on the web.
So it's exactly the same equation,
just express differently and you can use either form,
whichever is more convenient.
Okay.
The other equation looks like this,
a five log d over 10 parsecs.
And this relates one object,
but it relates both kinds of magnitude to each other.
So the first one is two different objects,
but only one of the magnitude,
the other's one object.
And it relates to the two different kinds of magnitudes to each other and to the
distance to the object.
Uh,
and as you can see this,
both of these equations actually have three unknowns.
One,
two,
three.
That means you've got to know two things in order to find out the third.
Uh,
and that brings me to the comment I want to make about problem to a,
on the current problem set.
Uh,
you are asked in this problem to determine the difference between the absolute
magnitude of one kind of star called type one Cepheids.
So I label it,
see one,
uh,
and another kind of stark type two Cepheids,
which I labeled C to.
Uh,
and if you're asked to,
and,
and this difference is called,
I don't know,
Delta,
AMC or something like that.
Um,
if you're [inaudible] and having been asked to do this,
the logical thing that you might try to do is say,
all right,
I'm going to use one or the other of these equations.
I'm not sure in advanced which to compute this one.
Then I'm going to compute this one and I'm going to subtract the two.
And that's going to give me the answer.
That approach will fail.
Okay?
That doesn't work in this particular case because you don't actually have enough
information to compute either one of these things.
You do have enough information to compute the difference.
Uh,
and let me just give you a very brief hint on how you might go about doing that.
let's see.
Let me take a new piece of paper here.
Write down,
uh,
m c one minus M C one is five log d c One over 10 parsecs.
And now write the exact same equation down for c two,
where the two different distances are the distances you get by assuming a one or
the other kinds of,
uh,
of these magnitudes.
This equation,
this equation too.
Now let's subtract one minus two.
So then you get little MC,
one minus little MC,
two minus big MC,
one minus big MC two is equal to five,
log d c One
minus log D C Two.
Okay,
now here's the trick.
Uh,
turns out,
uh,
for reasons that you had better.
Tell me a and t apps take note that we really want them to say why this is true.
Now that I've told them it is,
uh,
this is zero.
The two,
uh,
the two apparent magnitudes are the same.
And so that means that this side of the equation is what you want.
It's the difference between these two,
these two magnitude.
And then over here you have to use one of these log rules,
log of x minus log of y.
If you remember back to 11th grade is log of x over y.
And if you use that,
it turns out that you have information elsewhere in the problem,
which we'll tell you what you need to know,
uh,
about the distances.
And so in this way you can solve for the difference without actually being able
to determine either one of these two things.
So we'll just leave it at that for the moment.
If you have problems,
there's the usual forum,
there's the usual office hours,
uh,
but,
but ponder this,
uh,
that's uh,
basically how the problem has to do
okay.
Problems with magnitude.
Okay.
If you,
if you,
if you do have some,
let,
let us know because this is going to be critical for solving,
uh,
basically problems for the whole rest of the class.
Okay.
All right.
Yes,
go ahead.
This,
uh,
this is log d,
c one over 10 parsecs minus log DC to over 10 parsecs.
That's just subtracting the two right hand sides of this equation.
But then you get to do the log thing and divide the,
divide them instead,
which is fis to this on the,
on this log subtraction.
Okay.
Let me remind you why we're putting ourselves through this pain.
Uh,
recall why we started doing this in the first place.
The goal was to figure out how to measure the Hubble Diagram.
The Hubble diagram is this diagram of velocity,
which you can measure by red shift versus distance.
And the whole reason we embarked on this adventure in magnitudes was because
that's how that's a critical component in how you determined that distance.
But if you've got a bunch of,
um,
of galaxies and you measure these two quantities for each one of them,
what you discover,
what Hubble discovered,
what Edwin Hubble discovered many years ago,
is that they line up,
you get this perfect,
well not quite perfect,
but close to it.
Uh,
there's beautiful straight line.
If you measure a bunch of these things and the way you represent that straight
line is,
uh,
with this equation where h is Hubble's constant.
And so that's the purpose of all this magnitude stuff,
is to be able to determine the y axis of this plot.
What I now want to do is talk the implications of this observational fact that
the guy that galaxies lineup on this line,
it turns out this is one of the most profound plots in all of astrophysics and
possibly all of science.
Because what this implies is first of all,
that the universe is expanding.
And hence,
uh,
the,
it's the basis for the whole big bang theory of cosmology.
Uh,
and by,
uh,
performing relatively simple calculations using this quantity age,
you can determine the age of the universe
and the ultimate fate of the universe.
Not Bad,
uh,
for a relatively simple algebraic equation.
Yes.
Huh.
Oh,
fate.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll get,
I'll get back to that.
Uh,
the,
the big question in cosmology is,
you know,
the universe is now expanding.
The question is,
will it continue to expand,
in which case the universe just gets sparse and cold and boring and expands
forever until there's,
you know,
one pathetic hydrogen atom,
every cubic mega parsec of space,
or alternatively,
it could stop slow down and re collapsed into something called a big crunch,
uh,
and,
which is sort of the big bang run backwards.
Uh,
and basically the whole thing turned into a massive black hole.
these are,
uh,
you know,
this is Andy again,
fire or an ice,
I guess.
Uh,
and it can be computed,
uh,
and in,
in ways we'll describe later.
Okay.
So here's what I wanna do.
I wanna I want to start understanding,
uh,
how this plot and this little equation gives you all these wonderful things.
I'm going to go on for a little while,
then we'll pause and we'll do one of these Q and a sessions because this is sort
of the heart of the Big Bang theory.
And so we'll do one of these things that we did when we were talking about
relativity where you talk to each other and come up with questions.
So if you've got questions along the way,
by all means ask them.
Uh,
but,
uh,
we will have a specific moment,
a little ways down the line where we actually pause and,
uh,
and do this on purpose.
So everybody keep,
keep thinking as we go along.
What are your questions?
What don't you understand?
Or what questions could you ask to understand more than what I've just told you?
Okay,
here we go.
Imagine a one dimensional universe
just cause it's easy for me to write down
and here's our one dimensional universe.
It's all strung out on a line.
Here's the line.
Uh,
and it's got a bunch of galaxies on it.
Let's label these galaxies a,
B,
c,
d,
e,
and f,
uh,
and these galaxies are spaced evenly.
Let us imagine and we'll give them coordinates.
So this is at 0.0 0.1,
0.2 and so forth.
Okay?
Now next thing we're going to do,
the universe is going to double in size.
So we're just going to stretch the thing.
The whole thing is going to get stretched.
So here's our universe,
and now
f are further apart by a factor of two.
Hey,
B,
c,
d,
e,
F and F,
a.
You know,
we imagined stays at the saint coordinate.
If our coordinate system starts with a,
this means B is now at to see is it four,
six,
eight,
and 10.
Okay.
And let us imagine that it takes one time unit one year or something like that
for this doubling to take place.
Now we're going to ask if you sit,
if you live in galaxy a,
if you live on planet a and you observe the distance and velocity of all these
other galaxies,
uh,
what's it gonna look like?
So a observer on a,
uh,
and so we're going to observe a particular galaxy,
one of these other galaxies.
Uh,
we're going to write down the distance,
uh,
will choose the distance at the start because it's going to change them.
We're going to,
uh,
evaluate how that galaxy has moved.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
the total,
the distance changed.
And then over here we're going to get the velocity.
The velocity is going to be,
uh,
the change in distance,
divided by the change in time,
which we've defined to be one time yet.
Okay.
So galaxy be galaxy be start at a distance of one away from us cause it starts
at one gay star,
tits in a row.
Uh,
it moved from one to two a and that gives it a change in distance of one,
and therefore it's velocity over this time it's changed in distance by one.
It's taken one time unit.
The velocity is one divided by one equals one.
Okay.
The algebras easy.
So how about c?
C starts to away.
It's motion.
It goes from two away to four away.
And so the change in its distances to,
uh,
and,
since it takes one time unit to do it,
it's velocity is two over one,
which is equal to we,
which is equal to two seat Algebra simple.
But I screw it up,
right Beth,
and he's laughing at me,
uh,
and well might,
but I caught myself.
All right.
And so on down the line,
I could repeat this,
a,
this simple exercise.
D E F start at three,
four and five,
uh,
goes from three to six,
from four to eight,
uh,
from five to 10.
And their velocities are three,
four,
and five,
respectively.
And so if I plot distance,
uh,
vs velocity,
I'll get points lined up just like this.
And so basically what happens is this,
if you take a set of points on a coordinate system and you simply stretched the
coordinate system,
what happens is that the further away you start,
the greater the stretches.
And so,
uh,
there is a correlation between how far away you start and how fast,
the thing receives from you.
Now this is true,
regardless of where a of which,
uh,
point you sit on.
Let's sit.
Let's imagine that we sit on point that the observer is now on point
e.
So on point e we're now going to,
uh,
which galaxy,
initial distance motion,
uh,
velocity.
So this is the same plot of charges before e let's look at f starts at a
distance of one because it's one unit away.
Uh,
the motion.
Okay.
At the start it's uh,
let me take,
let's take a quick look at how this is set up here.
Yes,
he is at four.
So at the start the distances between four and five,
which is one,
and it goes to a distance of Eight,
eight,
which is where he ends up and 10,
which is where f ends up.
So that is a change,
uh,
of two,
no change of one.
Right,
because it's gone from one a way to,
to away the velocities want.
Yeah.
If we look at d,
it starts at a distance of one goes starts at four to three.
That's one separation goes to eight to six.
That's a separation of two.
Delta d is again,
equal to one velocity is equal to one
that's looked for example at B,
that starts three away and it starts from four B.
See ya from four to one,
and it goes to from eight to two.
So that's uh,
a difference of six year difference of three there.
And so Delta d is equal to three until the velocity is once again three.
And so you get the exact same plot with different galaxies cause you're sitting
in a different place.
So it doesn't matter which galaxy you're sitting on,
you see the exact same ratio of distance to velocity and you create the exact
same Hubble flow no matter which galaxy you sit on,
uh,
in this,
in this little toward universe.
So that's the key point that if you take a coordinate system and you expand it,
you naturally get this relationship between distance and velocity or to turn it
around.
If you observe this relationship between distance and velocity,
then what you're looking at is a system in which all the coordinates are,
are,
uh,
in which you've simply stretched the coordinate system.
Okay.
Now
this give rise to this analogy with this,
with this stretching one dimensional line,
uh,
gives rise to two questions people have,
which,
which I like to call unquestioned because,
uh,
there are actually questions that arise because of the analogy,
not because of the way the universe works.
Uh,
one question is Q one,
where is the center?
You know,
here's your line.
It's expanding,
right?
Yeah.
But somewhere in the middle here around C or d,
and our thing is,
is the center away from which everything is expanded?
Uh,
so that's one question.
And the second question is,
what is it expanding into?
You know,
uh,
here you have a little universe and it's moving outward.
Uh,
and so what's going on over here?
What was there before the universe moved into it?
Uh,
these kinds of questions,
uh,
and those kinds of questions,
come about because this is actually a bad analogy,
this straight line universe.
So let me give you a slightly better one.
We'll stick with a one dimensional universe,
but now we'll do it this way.
Here's a one dimensional universe.
You have to stay on the line.
So here's,
yeah,
whatever,
and it's going to expand and it's going to expand it to something that looks
like this.
and all of what we just did about the velocity and so forth remains the same.
Uh,
but,
uh,
notice that this system is unbounded.
There's no edge.
There's no place where you can say,
uh,
this is the end of the universe.
Because if you traveled around,
it could just come back to where you were and therefore there's also no center.
And where does it expand into?
It expands into a dimension that if you're a one dimensional creature,
you can't experience,
cause it's,
it's the whole thing is being pushed out.
But if you're forced to live on this,
on this circle,
you can't even,
uh,
you have no comprehension of what it expands into.
It expands into a higher dimension.
Okay.
But all of this stuff about,
you know,
velocity and distance remains basically the same.
Okay.
Here's a two dimensional analogy.
Let's see this,
uh,
this is,
so I made a little,
a little diagram of the old campus.
Here's Linsley Chittenden where we're sitting right now.
Yes.
Uh,
here's The statue of Abraham Pearson.
this is,
uh,
the gate between Durfee and right.
Here's Phelps.
Great.
Here's Vanderbilt.
Uh,
this is harkness tower and here Starbucks.
Okay,
you fall.
That's all that's important,
right?
Uh,
so you following me with that?
and what I did was I took this little picture and I took it to the Xerox machine
and I blew it up by 20%.
So here's the exact same diagram,
blown up by 20%.
So now supposing we're sitting of Lindsley Chittenden,
which we happened to be doing,
uh,
and the universe expanded by 20%,
or are a little corner of the universe expanded by 20%.
Here's what would happen.
Now notice what's happening.
Every object in the universe is moving away from us.
See,
here's where harkness was,
and now it's moved a little further in a straight line away from us.
Here is Pearson.
And he's moved a little further straight away from us.
And here's Phelps and it's moved a little further straight away from us.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
let me race those lines because what I want to demonstrate is that if you're
anywhere else in this universe,
the exact same thing happens here.
We're now a sitting on that statue and Lindsley cit is moving away from us.
Harkness is moving away from us.
Phelps is moving away from us.
Starbucks is moving away from us and so forth.
Similarly,
if you're sitting in Starbucks waiting for students to come by or something,
uh,
the exact same thing happens and now,
because the distances are greater,
you can see the effect that the velocity is greater at greater distances.
Uh,
if I'm looking down at Vanderbilt and only move,
it moves straight away from me,
but only a little bit.
If I'm looking all the way across all campus,
this gate moves a lot of weight from me.
And so once again,
you have a situation in which,
uh,
the further away some everything is moved,
everything is moving away from you,
but the further away it is,
the faster it's moving away,
right?
And that's just a consequence of the fact that you have taken this,
uh,
this geometry and expanded it.
And so wherever you sit in an expanding,
uh,
in an expanding geometry,
every object you see,
we'll be moving directly away from you.
And the further away it is,
the faster it will be moving,
which is Hubble's law.
So,
uh,
oh,
and one other thing about this,
this nice analogy here,
let us imagine for a second that this tiny piece of a tiny universe is actually,
uh,
not a flat plane,
but it's sitting on a curved surface,
which is curved all the way round into a big ball.
That's actually not so hard to imagine it because it's true.
Uh,
this sits on the surface of the earth.
And so what is happening when this thing blows up by 20% is basically somebody
has taken,
you know,
taking a valve to the earth and has blown the earth up by a factor of 20% and
that would have this effect and it would have the exact same effect everywhere
else on the surface of the earth and the earth,
you know,
uh,
where is the center of the surface of the earth?
You can answer the question where is the center of the earth?
But you can't answer this question of where's the center of the surface of the
earth?
Because wherever you sit,
whether you're sitting at Starbucks or in Phelps Gate or uh,
you know,
in Los Angeles somewhere or wherever,
if they blow the Earth up by 20%,
you're going to see this exact same effect.
Everything will be moving away from you.
The further away something is,
the faster it will be moving.
So
that's the one,
yes,
go ahead.
Yeah.
Talk.
Yes,
yes.
Good question.
If something's far away from you,
will it be appear,
appear to be moving at the speed of light?
Yes,
it will.
And that's one of the fundamental differences between,
uh,
the motion of an object due to what's called the Hubble float due to the
expansion and ordinary motion of,
of,
of objects.
Now something's moving faster than the speed of light.
Of course.
Uh,
you can't,
you can't see it because the light from that is red shifted down to greater than
infinite wave length.
So the photons don't have any energy left.
Uh,
but,
but let me come back to that question after I do one more thing.
That's a good question here.
Here's the thing I want to do.
Um,
so
why
we've had the one dimensional case,
the circle,
we've the two dimensional case,
the expanding sphere course.
What we want us the three dimensional space case.
Here we are in three dimensions.
Someone is expanding the universe.
So everywhere we look,
everything is going away from us.
And the further away it is,
the faster it's going.
Uh,
what's it expanding into?
Well that we have a little more trouble visualizing,
right?
Cause in one dimension you can visualize this circle expanding onto the plane in
two dimensions.
You can be imagined this,
the spherical surface expanding,
uh,
in three dimensions.
We can't imagine what it's expanding into.
That's,
that's,
that's beyond us.
Uh,
and so having had this failure of the imagination,
what do you do?
You resort to mathematics.
That's what we always do.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
imagine that every object,
has a,
uh,
position,
which is dean noted by three coordinates,
three spacial coordinates,
x,
y,
and Z.
Uh,
but now let's imagine that every object's position has,
is,
has this coordinate system times and,
uh,
a scale factor,
which is a function of t.
So it's a scale factor
times.
Okay.
Uh,
uh,
coordinate position.
And there are two ways that things can change their position.
One is they can move,
they can change their xyz position.
This is the equivalent of somebody walking across the old campus.
You walk from Starbucks to Phelps Gate or something like that,
and you change your x,
y,
z coordinate position by moving through space.
So,
uh,
changes in position,
which is to say velocity
can be accomplished in two ways.
One is,
oops,
where's my
one is a motion through the coordinate system.
Okay.
That is to say changing your x,
Y,
and z.
This is called peculiar motion.
That's a jargon and it's called peculiar because one object can have a different
peculiar emotion from,
uh,
from every other.
It's peculiar in the old fashioned sense,
meaning specific to one object.
Uh,
so you have a peculiar motion that's all your own.
I have one that's all mine as we move through x,
Y,
and z.
But the other is,
uh,
just the effect of the change.
And in particular,
in the case of the current university increase,
uh,
in the scale factor
and these two kinds of philocity,
uh,
are conceptually different from each other,
because you don't have to do anything to have to change your position in this
way.
You just sit there,
you don't expend any energy,
you don't have,
uh,
any requirement to expend energy or to exert a force or to do any of these
things that we ordinarily do to change our position.
You just sit there in the universe,
expands you or expand to your position.
And that's why,
going back to your question,
that's why it's possible for this kind of velocity to turn out to be greater
than the speed of light if it's far enough away.
Uh,
whereas it's not possible here.
What the effect of having a,
this kind of velocity be fast than the speed of light does is it makes the
objects impossible to see,
uh,
because uh,
photons coming off them would be red shifted into,
uh,
into oblivion.
Uh,
and so you can't actually see them in this imposes a kind of cosmic event
horizon similar in kind to the event horizons around black holes.
You can't see events on the other side of these horizons.
All right,
let me go backwards in time.
Back in time to when this scale factor a of t is equal to zero.
So if,
if the scale factor is expanding and you know,
the old campus,
whatever is expanding,
uh,
and you and you reverse time and you think about what happened long ago,
it must have been smaller.
So this a factor must've been smaller.
And if you go back a sufficient amount in time and go back to the point where a
is equal to zero,
so then what does the old campus look like?
It looks like this,
right?
It's all been imagined.
I take a xerox machine and I,
uh,
and Id Xerox id magnify the thing,
by uh,
uh,
down to 0% of its original size or zero plus epsilon.
Perhaps.
Uh,
what,
what does that little diagram looks like?
It looks like a tiny little dot.
A a single point except it isn't a single point.
What it is,
is it's many points superposed on each other.
And not only is the old campus in there,
imagine you've taken this sphere that is the earth and collapsed it to radius
down to zero.
Uh,
not only the old campus is there,
but so's the rest of new haven sows.
Connecticut's sows.
Los Angeles sews the whole rest of the surface of the earth.
All of the points that will eventually make the surface of the earth are super
posed on one another.
And yet,
uh,
the whole geometry of the earth,
of the old campus,
whatever,
uh,
is already,
somehow encoded in that point because,
uh,
you know,
you're taking zero times x,
Y,
Z for every point.
But then if you increase this so that it becomes epsilon or some nonzero number
times x,
y,
Z,
then you already get a did geometry of,
uh,
the old campus in everything else on the surface of the earth.
So it is wrong to think of the Big Bang as starting at a point and expanding
into space.
Uh,
that's kind of the impression that the word,
the Big Bang,
uh,
gives you and you think naturally enough of an explosion,
where there's something at a point explodes into empty space,
but that's not right.
All the,
all the space,
all the empty space is contained in that point.
It's all in there.
It's just,
it's all multiplied by zero.
So it all comes out to being on top of each other in the same place.
How are we doing?
Wonderful.
Uh,
okay.
Um,
that the essence of,
uh,
the big bang of the whole idea of the big bag,
that what is happening is that the whole coordinate system of the universe is
multiplied by this constant.
And that constant changes in time.
It gets bigger.
Uh,
and that fact is inferred from the observations of these galaxies,
uh,
that you observe galaxies and that they're moving away from us.
But more than that,
that the,
that there's a linear relationship between how far away from us they are and how
fast they're moving.
That implies this kind of coordinate expansion.
And if you run it in reverse,
it implies a,
an origin to the universe at some specific time in the past.
All right,
let's have questions.
I tell you what,
talk to each other,
come up with good questions.
Uh,
and remember how I remember how we do this.
When you,
when you come up with a question,
can be either to explain some of this or to expand upon it.
When you're ready with a question,
put your hand up.
I'll answer a few of them while other people are getting their questions
together.
And then,
uh,
then we'll answer as many of them as we have time for in the remainder of the
class.
So talk to each other,
talk amongst yourselves,
come up with a question,
any question,
all questions are good,
uh,
and see what you can do.
I'll come around and try and answer some of these.
Yeah.
So talk to each other.
By all means.
Yes.
A center of the Universe isn't there?
No.
There's gotta be a point in the universe at which like all other points,
all the points that are farthest away from that point.
No.
Expanding really fast,
right?
No,
no.
Well,
that's true of every point of the universe.
That's true of every point in the universe.
If you're sitting on the statue of Pearson,
everything is,
everything is the same.
Distance is moving away from you by the same amount.
That's true of every point.
Yeah.
Imagine a three dimensional thing,
expanding it.
The fourth dimension,
the way the surface of a sphere expands into three.
You switched from expansions,
getting close together.
Point Oh,
oh,
we'll talk about that later.
You can imagine that gravity is going to slow the expansion down.
But at the moment,
I'm just thinking about running backwards in time.
Yeah.
Or could,
yeah,
yeah.
So you had like fake event horizon,
so something could be like a period of removing yeah,
that's normal.
If it hurts,
you can't pass allocation between,
right.
But could you relay information?
Yes.
But by the time you had done that,
uh,
that is,
say the universe is expanding faster than the information would get to you.
Uh,
so you know,
by the time you've moved your information from here to here,
the distance from here to here,
his expanded.
Uh,
and so it's not actually getting any closer.
Okay.
Let's,
let's,
let's have,
let's have a few of these.
Yes,
go ahead.
First.
Essentially,
I didn't understand why it's zero times the coordinate,
why there's a point at all and why there's just nothing.
Why there's not
well,
uh,
okay.
So,
uh,
if a is equal to zero here,
then all events are at zero comma zero comma zero.
So that point of zero comma zero comma zero is occupied.
If you think of want to think of it that way,
it's the point at the point in question is the one at zero zero,
zero.
And if you have anything in here times zero,
that's where you're going to end up.
And as you go backwards and run this scale factor down to zero,
as you think about going back in time,
uh,
everything's going to,
everything's going to end up,
uh,
closer and closer to zero.
And then at the moment when this equals zero,
it's all piled on top of itself.
That makes sense.
Yeah,
go ahead.
MMM,
no,
no.
Uh,
Imagine,
oh,
in the other dementia.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
In the higher dimension.
That's true.
Well,
okay,
let me back off.
That's true.
If you have a constant curvature,
you could imagine something that,
you know,
looks like this,
that also expands in exactly the same way,
uh,
and what creates the curvature of space,
time gravity.
And so we're going to end up in a situation where,
uh,
we're going to be able to determine what the curvature of space is by seeing how
much mass there is.
So this actually back to part two of the course
differently.
Huh?
Would that time could move differently too?
Yup.
Yes.
We'll circle when he said that,
uh,
things expand into a higher dimension.
Okay.
So imagine you're a one dimensional creature.
You can only go on a lie.
Uh,
and but your line unbeknownst to you is curved so that it ends on itself.
that then ext the line expands,
the circle expand.
Uh,
and what do you think is happening?
You think suddenly all the distances are greater,
uh,
but you can't perceive what it's expanding into because that's a second
dimension in your constrained to move on the line.
Similarly,
if you're an aunt or something moving on the surface of the earth and you have
no understanding that there's up and down,
uh,
and the earth suddenly increases in size,
you have no,
you have no perception of the dimension you're moving into.
Well,
uh,
our perception is of a three dimensional universe.
So if you say,
uh,
okay,
what happens when the scale factor gets bigger?
Uh,
you can write it down mathematically and do all these calculations in what you
have to imagine.
Uh,
if you want to have a conceptual understanding of this is that there's some,
uh,
fourth spacial dimension into which this three dimensional spaces moving into,
but we can't perceive that.
Uh,
so it's better to do it mathematically cause it,
it's hard on the brain,
uh,
to imagine that fourth dimension.
And so there's,
and there's basically two ways to think about this.
One is by analogy,
you think of the one dimensional creature and what it thinks about the second
dimension or the two dimensional creature,
what it thinks about the third dimension.
And then you just sort of take this leap of faith into us moving into the fourth
or you have to write things down mathematically.
Those are the only two options you have actually picturing this is not going to
happen.
Yes.
Speed up this process.
Ah,
interesting question.
Would we,
if we cracked up this process,
some,
would we actually,
you know,
be able to,
uh,
take out our tape measure and notice that the distance between here and
Starbucks has increased?
No.
Here's why we are not we,
that is to say,
you,
me,
our bodies,
whatever,
uh,
are not participating in the expansion of the universe at the moment.
Why?
Because the molecules in our body are being held together by other forces,
chemical forces.
We are being held.
The Earth has held together by gravitational forces,
uh,
and that those forces have stopped the expansion of the universe locally,
but not globally.
And that's why you have to go out and measure this stuff with galaxies.
Otherwise you'd be able to,
you know,
measure it with this.
Now,
of course,
then there's the problem.
The ruler also expand this kind of stuff.
But,
uh,
but,
but in fact,
what happens is that locally local objects,
by which I mean our own galaxy and anything smaller,
are held together by other forces.
Picture of balloon expanding.
So that's the two dimensional case.
This balloon expand and put a bunch of leather patches on the balloon.
So those leather patches don't expand.
But the distance between,
because they're held together by something,
something else.
But the,
but the distance between them does.
Yes.
What causes the expansion?
Oh,
that's theology.
Uh,
no,
seriously.
It's an,
it's an initial condition.
Uh,
something,
something at the start at t equals zero,
where this a a is a,
uh,
where this a is zero.
Uh,
so you're starting with a of with this scale factor of zero,
but the derivative isn't zero.
Uh,
it's expanding a is increasing.
Why,
why is it increasing by the particular amount?
It is,
uh,
you have to think of that as,
as being a parameter of the universe.
Uh,
it's one of the things about these sort of like the speed of light.
Why is that the quantity it is or why is the gravitational constant fee the
value it is,
uh,
it's one of the parameters that governs our universe.
Why those particular parameters?
Uh,
that's uh,
not quite a science question.
Uh,
and we don't know.
you can turn it around.
You can make the following.
Interesting point.
If it wasn't expanding at approximately the rate it is,
we wouldn't be here to notice it because if it was expanding a whole lot slower,
um,
then it would never have gotten big enough.
Force four stars to condense out.
If it was expanding a whole lot faster,
uh,
the whole,
all the atoms would be spread out so far that again,
stars could never form.
So you can make this interesting argument that why you don't know why it has
this particular value.
It's very important that it does because otherwise we wouldn't be here to
observe it.
This is a form of argumentation called the anthropic principle.
It is a highly debated among scientist,
whether this is a scientific argument or not.
Uh,
but it's amusing either way.
So yes.
Great.
Well,
you go back before a and you're in trouble.
Uh,
so,
okay,
so this is,
this is another one of these unquestioned,
uh,
the,
it's usually phrased as well what happened before the big bang.
Right?
And that's the equivalent question.
Uh,
and again,
that's a theological question.
Uh,
uh,
your,
it's like asking the question of what's going on inside and a veteran.
You can write down equations,
you can talk about it,
but it's untestable by its very nature.
Uh,
and so something,
something have this by the way is why,
uh,
the Catholics like the Big Bang theory so much,
in fact,
the,
um,
uh,
mathematics,
the relativistic mathematics that described the big bang and the expansion of
the universe were worked out by a man named [inaudible] who was a,
who was a Catholic priest.
It was a Jesuit.
Uh,
they love this,
uh,
because it gives you a creation moment.
Uh,
it kind of gives you a scientifically verify creation moment.
John Paul was very enthusiastic about astrophysics.
He used to throw big conferences in the Vatican,
give speech,
give after dinner speeches.
Uh,
there's a thing called the Vatican astrophysical observatory.
They have a bunch of Jesuits.
They run a telescope in Arizona.
They do research into this.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
if you want to see science and religion converge,
uh,
you want to run away from biology as fast as you can.
Uh,
and talk to us about cosmology.
what I don't understand is why is why the,
the,
uh,
sort of fundamentalist type worry so much about biology where all the science is
dead set against them,
whereas in the case of a astrophysics,
now of course it is possible if you take an atheistic point of view to come up
with all kinds of clever ways to avoid this creation event.
Uh,
but again,
it,
it stops being science at a certain point.
It becomes another odd kind of theology.
And we'll talk about that perhaps a little bit.
Uh,
but if you want a place where science turned out to be congruent to at least
certain kinds of non fundamentalist religious beliefs,
you're way better off in astrophysics,
then you are in biology.
Yeah.
Oh,
go ahead.
No,
that's a fourth spacial dimension that I'm talking about.
In this case,
it's expanding into a dimension which,
uh,
we don't perceive,
or at least that's one way of conceptualizing it.
Uh,
you know,
we don't get to,
uh,
to deal with that dimension.
So it's,
again,
it's a kind of a,
it's a concept.
It's not a,
it's not a,
it's not necessarily a physical thing.
Yes.
You said that.
All
right.
Just wondering,
does that mean like meaning that anything that will ever
yeah,
yeah.
It has to be,
think of all the points that now exist in the universe,
multiply them by zero and they're all on top of each other.
Yes.
Um,
so if you were to go really,
really fast in a straight line,
right,
you eventually ended up,
ah,
so this is the question of what is the curvature of the universe?
Is it in fact like this analogy with a circle or the surf surface of this
sphere,
if you go forever,
you come back to,
you are,
that depends on what the overall curvature of the universe turns out to be.
That depends on how much mass it contains because mass curve space,
uh,
and so that is,
that's a question that empirically answerable,
uh,
we think the answer is no.
Uh,
in any case though,
it would take you longer at the speed of light then the age of the universe to
accomplish it.
So,
uh,
so even if it were a positively curved in this sense that it,
the rejoined itself,
you wouldn't actually be able to make that voyage?
No.
Well,
you would,
you might eventually,
unless the universe is expanding faster than you can move,
right.
Uh,
this is this question.
This goes back to the question of camp.
Parts of it expand faster than the speed of light and he answers his guests.
So yeah,
you take off on this voyage to the back of your own head,
you know,
going in that direction,
you're going to end up here,
uh,
except the universe is expanding faster than you can go.
And so you don't necessarily end up back there.
Yes.
Oh.
One of the things that we haven't talked about is,
is the expansion rate constant.
Might it be fit?
The universe is expanding,
but perhaps slowing down,
why would it slow down?
It's full of mass.
Gravity slows things down.
Uh,
and so in principle,
if you've got enough mass,
the universe will stop,
turn around and fall backwards,
uh,
and well,
and you can compute from,
we will compute next period how fast you have to go to make that happen.
Or contrary how dense the universe has to be to stop it.
Uh,
and so what you expect is the universe is slowing down because you know,
you don't know how much it slowing down,
whether it will stop the expansion up,
but you expect it to be slowing down.
The punchline of this whole part of the course in order to anticipate where
we're going is that in fact,
we can measure the change in the expansion rate and it's speeding up,
not slowing down.
This is very disturbing because it means there's some kind of pervasive cosmic
antigravity,
uh,
which we called dark energy because we don't know what it is.
Uh,
and that's basically the punchline of this whole section of the course.
but,
uh,
but you could imagine that the,
that there is a change in the expansion rate,
either positive or negative,
uh,
and that therefore various different outcomes are possible.
Yeah.
The Big Bang and sort of expanded the whole geometry of the universe where a big
crunch like gravity would only call up the optics.
No,
no,
no.
It turns out,
uh,
it,
you might imagine that,
but you'd be wrong.
It turns out that the,
uh,
this scale factor,
you can write down a differential equation for the scale factor and that it's
the scale factor that stops,
turns around and comes back.
Uh,
now it is the case that when it's going out,
the particular objects the universe contains,
are different because,
uh,
because of the peculiar emotions,
it starts out much more evenly spread and then gradually stuff accumulates due
to gravity.
And you get,
when you're coming back,
you get a lot of individual points rather than a smooth distribution of matter.
But that has to do with peculiar emotions,
not the overall motion of the universe.
One more.
And then we got to,
uh,
continue this next time.
Yes,
go ahead.
Minus a negative.
Right?
So before the big bank,
can you put a negative number in to that?
A,
this gets you into exactly the same kind of mathematical difficulty as moving
inside an event horizon.
All you can actually write down a metric for the whole universe,
uh,
and you change all the signs when that happens and you get into a very similar
kind of problem.
So mathematically you could compute a bunch of stuff.
Uh,
the physical meaning of that is not if,
first of all,
if first of all,
the,
uh,
the fact that that mathematics actually works in the real world is impossible to
determine.
And the physical nature of that up consequences of that,
uh,
are,
questionable.
All right.
Stop.